[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jerry dulac
covers the steelers for the pittsburgh
post gazette and kind enough to join us
uh jerry thanks for joining us what was
the reaction when uh you found out that
the st
the steelers are gonna face a team
probably with their third string running
back
well i will tell you this dan and good
morning that even yesterday when they
held their walk through
uh with the idea that dobbins and
um mark ingram might play
uh they didn't alter their approach or
their plan
or anything else they have the same plan
going in
for gus edwards excuse me and um
rg3 as they would for lamar jackson
and jk dobbins and or mark ingram
so it doesn't affect them one way or the
other
it probably benefits them that j.k
dobbins isn't playing
but they dan they're very much aware of
what happened last year in the season
finale when rg3 played
and gus edwards and the ravens still ran
for 203 yards
and one thing they do know that they
want to do
or have to do is change their scheme how
they defend
the ravens because in the last three
games the numbers like
811 yards the the ravens have rushed for
against the steelers including that 265
a month ago so
that's what they know they have to
change but the personnel
isn't going to ch isn't going to dictate
to them how they are going to defend the
ravens
i had a source earlier in the week
saying that john harbaugh was being a
hypocrite that they created this
now they're saying that they're being
persecuted picked on here
i'm just wondering about the steelers
side of this because it feels like
the steelers are the ones who didn't do
anything wrong but they're the ones
being punished to a certain degree
how are the steelers reacting to this
well other other than the game
being the thanksgiving game being
canceled and some of their young guys
uh coming out and saying that's bs and
then using the full word
and then saying it's a joke you know uh
juju smith schuster coming out and
saying you know
uh you know if the ravens can't control
their covert situation that should be on
them
uh forgetting the fact that that uh two
weeks earlier the steelers had five guys
on the list including ben roethlisberger
but the timing benefited them because
they could come off on saturday and play
on sunday
beyond that i think mike tomlin's
directive to them is as
always is just hey look just keep the
focus stay on it stay on the path we're
on
and um i i you know if anything maybe
they're getting a little antsy
um but hey look the same complaints are
coming out of pittsburgh not necessarily
from the state
from the team and the players but from
their fans and maybe internally there's
some oh you know we're getting the short
end of the stick
but i don't think that that permeates
the locker room mike tomlin won't allow
that to happen
but yeah i think every team feels
they're being picked on look at the
denver broncos dan they petitioned
the league every which way they could to
try and do something about that
quarterback situation
and and it didn't happen and so yeah in
pittsburgh they think baltimore is
getting
getting an advantage in baltimore they
think they're getting screwed
when was the last time you covered a
steeler team that had
this well least dramatic steeler team
in how many years well you know
uh it's funny because every year it
seems to come up i don't think there's
any question then the two years ago
with the le'veon bell situation in the
antonio brown situation
i don't think that drama could ever be
surpassed no matter what happens
and and i think because the steelers are
such a marquee team
and as you know being in the business
they are a team that moves the needle
and because of that they receive a lot
of attention it's also because they tend
to have a lot of the game's top stars
so and go back to antonio brown and
le'veon bell so
when those situations arise they get
magnified and people pay attention
because
it is the steelers and and so there
always seems to be this this
um cloud of drama surrounding them
but let's face it when you look at their
performance and their record you know
mike tomlins never had a losing season
in in 14 years um it's pretty amazing
it's testament to him
and to the organization that they kind
of forget their way
through that and and still still manage
to be successful
are they a balanced team or their
defensive minded team
well you know the funny thing right now
dan aside from the fact that they don't
run the ball very well
you know their offense is as good as
it's been i mean they're the only team
in the afc to score
24 more points in every game even kansas
city can't say that
um ben roethlisberger is having uh
arguably his best season certainly
statistically
um and and the the run defense has
actually
suffered the last three four weeks
i think they're a very well balanced
team they're a team that can score
points
and to me to me dan they are the one
team in the league that is equipped to
stop
any of these other offenses including
kansas cities now i'm not saying they
will
but they are equipped to do it because
you know they have all pros at all three
levels
they can they sack the quarterback they
have a pretty they have a larcenist
secondary they take the ball away
and yeah their mission devin bush i
thought that was a big big loss because
i thought he was the one player
they could least afford to lose because
they don't have anybody else like him
but when you look at cam hayward and
stefan tuitt up front and you got those
two edge guys
watt dupreeh and then a really solid
secondary with mika fitzpatrick
um you know they're they're they're
equipped to play however you want and
just
and to you know bottle up a team as as
as well as anybody in the lake can do it
when does the possibility of an
undefeated season become
a legitimate topic for the players to
talk about
i think buffalo you know once if they
can get past that in a couple weeks you
know see what happens with the ravens
then they have washington and i know
washington's been scoring some points
lately
but they are four and seven then they go
to buffalo and i think
excuse me i think that will be the key
they could be 12-0 going to buffalo
and if they come through that at 13-0
then i think it becomes a very real
possibility because
then it's then it's the colts and then
it's the you know then it's the season
ending game and let's say the buy is
still in place
nothing has changed and they get a bye
week then what do you do
in week 16 you go for an unbeaten season
or do you
you back off a little bit um you know
i've talked to a couple
former coaches around the league and
they all think it's probably a good idea
if they lose a game somewhere
i tend to agree just to get the the
specter and the pressure of an unbeaten
season off their back
and and you know then start focusing on
on the postseason so
but i i think uh i think uh two or three
weeks here when they head to buffalo is
going to be the key damn
great to talk to you jerry thanks for
making time have fun today we appreciate
it
well dan nice chatting with you jerry
dolak he covers the steelers for the
pittsburgh post gazette